going to start from the car park which
is where she came with the dog and the
kids dropped them off at school and then
we're going to walk along the road and
just give you an overview walk along the
road walk down by the river and then
from there we are going to walk around
the fields and try to get an idea of
what might have happened so that
happened at exactly 8 40. from here what
then what happened so Nicola came parked
up her car here she dropped off her kids
at school she would have taken her dog
Willow out of the car park as she
normally did and walked her along this
path next to the car park of the tennis
club and the school
yeah there we go and this is a very
normal route for Nicola almost every
single morning this is exactly what she
would have done her kids
coming to the school to our left as well
and this is a busy road Inskip down
there is where the family home is so she
would have come down this road and then
onto the road up there a very busy main
road yeah Blackpool Lane it is yeah and
the police have stressed about Blackpool
Lane because there are hundreds of cars
700 Vehicles yeah that would have passed
through that morning and so they are
clear they want to try and speak to
every single one of those drivers to get
as much dash cam footage as they
possibly can to try and piece together
uh what exactly has gone on so you want
to cross this road
and would have walked down this path
which heads up to not only the bridge
which she crossed but in fact the church
which she would have passed and she
would have come up here
to this Iron Bridge which again has been
another real focal point of the last
three weeks look at all these beautiful
ribbons daffodils that have been tied up
with messages Nicholas partner came down
here leaving a message on one of them as
well and as we just go a bit forward we
get to the other side of the bridge and
essentially the start
of the path which is next to the river
this is the path that runs along the
river wire and it was 8 43 yeah this
time
quite a pace she was walking out isn't
it yeah it was yeah it was we've you
know walked down she's got a dog with
her probably the dog you know running a
bit ahead of you you're talking about
yourself a river wire there
over two weeks before that morning she
had a visit from police because of
concerns for welfare yeah a medical team
went to the home on the 17th of January
and they haven't told us anything more
than that but we do know that the police
have referred themselves to the
complaints committee
um as a direct result of that um moment
but if we just pause here because before
we get
to the upper field it was around this
time roughly
about 850 that Nicola was then spotted
by another dog walker yeah someone who
knew her walking around the lower field
with their dog as well the two dogs
actually interacted before the other dog
walker went off and took the river path
which we've just come down and Nicola
then carried on with her dog Willow very
shortly she would have just been
finishing her email off
which goes to a boss
yeah and um and so she's looking at the
dog she's making sure the dog's all
right you know from my own experience
you keep an eye on them but you're doing
other things as well the Sheep across
the way they're just obviously keeping
an eye on what's going on and then she
sends the email yep at 8 53 police say
right now three weeks ago Nicola hit
send yep and an email was sent to her
boss yeah
so if you're just tuning our way we are
retracing the steps of Nicola bully
um three weeks ago today it's nine
o'clock and she would have been on a
team's call about now yep it was about a
minute about a minute's time or so she
logged into that team school I imagine
the meeting started at nine o'clock
Nicola logged in about one minute past
nine yeah she would have held the phone
out yeah yep she was at she was just
walking along this upper field here yeah
she
would have held the phone out in front
of her sorry police said and that's
where that's what you do isn't it yeah
you've got it on speaker yeah you hold
it out in front of you yeah
um and she wasn't talking she wasn't on
video it was just it would have been
slower here because she was listening to
what was being said yeah and again you
know as I mentioned her dad said in
relation to work she was in good spirits
she just as a mortgage advisor had just
got a deal through so she was happy
about that and you know she sent a an
email to her boss and she starts to join
a team's conversation the camera's not
on the um audio is not on but she is
holding it out and we know that because
somebody saw her right now yeah it was
at ten past nine here on the upper field
that somebody then saw Nicola a witness
that has been spoken to by police so
three weeks ago let's put this in
perspective three weeks ago ten past
nine in the morning yeah somebody saw
Nicola walking with her dog Willow here
you know just to illustrate you know
that this is where the dog walkers come
um all the time yeah
um her partner came along Paul
um and he's retraced these steps many
times hasn't he yeah he has he has and
he came down pretty much straight away
you know he wanted to see
what was the scene like what happened
here straight away good morning morning
sir how are you no no not at all good to
see you you're Olivia
it has been like that so you you
actually you saw the phone is that right
yeah yeah yeah you saw the phone that
Friday morning yes yeah and that was
around was it after half nine I I gave a
full statement to the police with the
exact time because excuse me because my
wife's
how's the last three weeks been
each day something new comes out doesn't
it yeah you know yeah yeah
and and in in terms of you know
when you saw phone lead and Willow who
you you knew who Nicola was no I didn't
you knew the willow that was it wasn't
you knew you knew what the you knew I'd
seen I'd see
um but both
both the orders of Willow yeah walking
they snug in the passport whilst I knew
them back there it's like I know your
face I didn't know the name yeah yeah
but but you I remember you actually
telling me when you saw the phone that
the lead and Willow you were like okay
I'm gonna keep an eye on it because
something doesn't feel right I thought
somebody had gone to the toilet in the
yeah you know that would have been that
was my mother I got about this red brick
building here and I uh this this is not
right this is the part of
the river where the police think that
she has gone into the water there's no
sign here at all of um you know any
scuffs or whatever yeah but this is
where her phone is found yeah well look
it's 9 20 yeah right now yeah
9 20 three weeks ago
Nicholas phone had moved to this bench
but we're at a very important juncture
right now okay it's 9 30.
she'd logged on about 901 it had
obviously started at nine o'clock yeah
um but she stayed logged on so police
say that the team's call ended 9 30.
but Nicola's phone remained logged on to
that team's call in other words she
hadn't ended the call so that happened
um
three weeks ago right now yeah
approximately police say it was 9 33
three weeks ago that the lady who who
owns a caravan Park just around the
corner here
actually spotted Nicholas phone spotted
Willow and spotted the harness she was
another dog walker so you know she she
noticed who Willow was noticed who
Willow belonged to and then that's when
things really kicked into action I know
the locals got involved yeah so that's
like they
the 45 minutes
um from when she dropped the children
off at school we walked we've walked to
her walk today starting in the car park
walking along Blackpool Lane going past
the 16th century Parish Church very
beautiful building walking down
to where we are and then going around
the loop the lower field and then up to
the upper field sending an email to her
boss saying hello to people that she
knew along the way dialing into attempts
called just after it started at nine
o'clock making a way to where we are now
we know well we know that her phone made
its way to here it was left on the bench
the dog was here the harness was here
there was literally no further sign of
Nicola and that has been the case for
the last three weeks it has been
perplexing for Lancashire police it has
been devastating for her family we'll
have continuing coverage here on Sky